[Applause]
maria kolesnikova has kept a very public
profile over the past four weeks
the last of the three women who took on
lukashenko who has not been forced to
flee belarus
this video according to her team shows
the door being shut on a black van she
has just been bundled
into shortly after 10 a.m this morning
in the centre of minsk
the police say they didn't take her her
lawyers have written to the kgb
the belarusian secret services to ask if
they have
it was brave of her to stay when
svetlana and veronica had both left
what was her logic in doing that she
promised
millions of belarusians that she would
stay in the country and continue
fighting for poor people's rights
because
now it's it's already not just to fight
for free elections it's just a fight for
basic civil rights just to feel
safe in the streets of your own city
[Music]
because what is going on in belarus in
the heart of europe is brutal
[Applause]
630 people arrested on sunday alone
more than 9 000 since protests began
hundreds with horrific bruising to show
for it
beaten and tortured in the back of
police vans and in the country's
detention centers
some blows were aimed at the knees my
knees swelled up and it was painful
not just to sit but to be in any
movement
in this position with our hands zip tied
we spent an hour or an hour and a half
until somebody started complaining of a
heart condition or chronic illness
we were in belarus shortly after the
reports of torture started coming out
human rights organizations said then
they wanted to see the eu
sanction those responsible i think they
need to have some kind of responsibility
now
and this is a part of the responsibility
i think that this is uh
they need to be in this sanction list
the
the head of means police the minister of
internal affairs and all these people
svetlana tikanovskaya was forced into
leaving the country shortly after the
elections
her jailed husband easy leverage for the
regime
kolesnikova's team believes she too may
have to strike a deal with the
authorities and leave the country
in a tweet the foreign secretary said
lukashenko's regime must make her safe
return their highest priority
the regime must cease brutalizing
protesters release political prisoners
and begin dialogue with the opposition
this is what kolesnikova told us before
the elections
they don't understand in what country
and involved
what time do they leave they don't speak
with people on the same language
they have already lost
the people have spoken loudly and often
but even if lukashenko has lost all
legitimacy
he still seems quite capable of holding
on to power
diana magnay sky news moscow